oh hi YouTube alright so the disaster
artist so I enjoyed this movie I had a
lot of fun with it but I mean I kind of
I expected that it's definitely the kind
of movie that's aimed at someone like me
if if you're not super familiar
I love garbage media a lot of people
actually on the on the previous couple
of blog commented on this right here
they're like what what is with that
what is that stack you have a stack of
ps3 games sitting there right beside you
and that's actually that is the stack of
shame that's from my weekly twitch
streams we are working our way through
mostly PlayStation 3 era just just
forgotten discarded maybe not very good
games a lot of most of them the vast
majority of them being movie tie-ins so
movie tie-in games and I I try very hard
to love these even though they're not
worth loving but the the root of this
experiment here of what we're doing with
the stack of shame is is to find the the
video game equivalent of movies that are
so bad they're good movies like the room
so far right now we actually have like
only only three that really meet that
qualification these three right here 50
cent blood on the sand battleship and
Dante's Inferno everything else fails in
some way most most of them fail simply
by being boring just like most bad
movies most bad movies fail simply VIPRE
by virtue of being not very entertaining
they're not fun to watch they're you
know you you can't say anything about
them they're not interesting they
they're just they're just
ugly slog for however long they referred
for an hour and a half or whatever for
two hours for four hours for six master
so so this is an experiment to try and
find that equivalent and now the room is
or sorry I shouldn't say the room the
disaster artist is a bit of a love
letter to so bad they're good movies but
it's also a profile of a very specific
one which is Tommy Wiseau is the room
and ie I had a lot of fun with it it was
entertaining there were parts of it that
for me as an individual got a little a
little too real so I have worked on some
very low budget sets before where the
kind of moments that the that the
disaster artist was recreating from the
production of the room or like yeah I've
been in scenarios like that
so scenario like you know sex scenes
where the director clearly doesn't
respect the privacy of the the actors
involved where safety and health and
human services and you know just the
general comfort of the crew and safety
of the crew were not high priorities
we're food and water were not adequately
provided we're working conditions were
were terrible and no one no one in
charge cared yeah I've I've been there
so when they go through the like end of
the second act in in the movie structure
which is where everything kind of starts
to starts to disintegrate and and fall
apart the that part of the
where they're making the room and Tommy
has turned into just a complete ogre of
a director and he's harassing and
insulting the crew and you know they're
they're working in a studio without
air-conditioning and there's no water on
set and you know the that that chunk of
the movie was really uncomfortable it
there there were some flashbacks so one
time I'm I'm on this set and for an
entire week the only food that they
provide us with are are soggy sandwiches
and not not normal kind of sandwiches
like they didn't get anyone catering to
do the sandwiches they just they just
had somebody in a back room making
sandwiches and I don't know where this
person learned to make a sandwich but it
was not Earth they were they were
slicing Tomatoes on a cutting board and
then without even mopping up the tomato
juice they would just put bread on it
and start making sense so you would get
soggy like tomato soaked sandwich and
the sandwich itself would be like you
would get a hummus and tomato sandwich
so so bread hummus a couple slices of
tomato more bread and and tomato juice
has soaked into the bread it was it was
I tell you what and then and then when
you're in that scenario when when you're
already having a stressful day because
there there is no budget and the
director and the producer don't know
what they want and everybody's kind of
already on edge and no one knows what
they're doing and you go to lunch and
somebody hands you
a soggy hummus and tomato sandwich your
soul dies you just you you just want to
curl up and end so yeah so that part of
the movie was definitely kind of close
to home kind of close to home for me and
the closest comparison that people are
gonna make or you're gonna hear a lot of
comparisons to Ed Wood and it's a very
good comparison because Ed Wood really
is kind of the only other sort of recent
movie of this kind and even then it's
not that recently that's ninety three
ninety ninety three ninety four you know
so the comparison is good in as far as
like they follow a similar sort of arc
of like you know it's it focuses on a
relationship between two people and then
uses that relationship to form the
backbone of the story of the making of a
movie and but that's kind of then they
diverge very sharply actually from that
because the thing is is that well Ed
Wood and Tommy was so are both terrible
terrible directors Ed Wood is is a was a
gleeful idiot he was incompetent as a
director he was he was no good at it but
by all sort of reports you know at least
until later in his life when when the
booze started to get to him he was just
just passionate and incompetent you know
that a lot of his came from like a lot
of his incompetence came from like they
would do a shot once and he would just
be happy with it he was overjoyed with
it things would go wrong and he'd just
be like we got it well good let's move
on whereas whereas was so is is an
egomaniac
he's he turned into an ogre on set he
turned he he just he's controlling he's
jealous he's not a nice person
and so yeah there so there is kind of a
significant divergence in there whereas
you know where we're at Wood is in a lot
of ways a lot more of a a celebration of
one man's misguided passion whereas this
is one a lot more about one dudes ego
one of the things that I am kind of of
two minds about though is is the the
framing of the framing of the ending the
movie doesn't really hold back like it
it's it's okay with painting Tommy and
in a negative light it it's not a hit
piece it's not out to make him look like
a monster but it's it's also like it's
not afraid to it's also kind of not
afraid to make him look like a monster
when he's being monstrous but at the end
of the film it does kind of fall into
this trap of you know monstrous
directors are ultimately worth its you
know they invoke Hitchcock and Kubrick
you know legendary awful people to work
for and work with and it's like oh but
look at the art that they created and
it's the movie so the disaster artist
ultimately kind of comes down a little
bit more towards you know that like oh
it was all worth it but in in a way it
really kind of is about the perversion
of that out tour theory like that this
very specific manifestation of out - or
theory where it's like you know that by
being
a dictator by being a monster that by
torturing your cast and crew that is how
you create great art and this this is
this is the counter thesis to that where
it's like okay by doing that you created
just accidental arts like the room is
awful it's it's terrible it's not it's
not good
it is legitimately a very bad movie it
just happens to be a deeply
entertainingly bad movie but yeah so
it's it's that you you you have been an
ogre you have been awful to your cast
and crew and you have produced garbage
but that garbage still on some level
speaks to people for none of the reasons
none of the reasons that you intended I
know that Tommy Wiseau has tried to play
off the room as like oh it was always
meant to be a dark that's that's that's
bullcrap just look at it it's clearly it
is clearly 100% sincere and it's just it
is a failure it is a failure of vision
and so yeah so there is kind of this
this perversion of that of that theory
and that it's like you know you can you
can go there you can do all of that and
you can be awful and it it isn't going
to it's not a magic spell for greatness
but at the same time it kind of like the
the final sort of moments of the
disaster artist sort of fall into this
like well if people enjoy it you know if
people enjoy it that's all that
ultimately matters and so yes it was
worth it even if your vision isn't what
ends up coming through and you know
there's so I would I would I would
appreciate that a lot more if the path
there wasn't
you know humiliating his actress and and
stuff like that one of the other things
that the movie doesn't play soft with is
acknowledging that Tommy kind of just
bought his way in like that that the
room exists because tommy was already
wealthy it's it's not some it's not the
product of you know hard work and
gumption it's it's explicitly the anti
product of hard work and gumption it's
it's the product of someone who had no
talent
we got fed up with needing talent hard
work and luck and just bought the thing
that he wanted and it's awful so so that
dimension of it does is is a a vein that
runs through runs through the disaster
artist the fact that Tommy basically
just was able to buy his dream and and
that it's it's it's not the product of
effort it's the product of money and
yeah so so there it's I think it could
have gone a little bit a little bit
harder for that angle of really kind of
embracing the identity of like hey the
room is is ultimately a complete
perversion of our normal narrative of
hardwork luck talent you know but it it
goes a little soft on that but I don't
think that say I don't think that's
that's a fatal flaw it's still a really
funny movie it's still a really
enjoyable movie I had I had an enjoyable
time with it the the two real the two
real moments included
so you know hey yeah you want to see you
guys see it
just see it don't see it